At this point, we need to have
finished installing X-Code.
So if you haven't yet,
pause this video, and
take a moment to finish
the installation.
Since I already have X-Code installed,
I'm ready to launch
the Maze application.
To launch the app, we need to first
launch X-Code, and you can do this by
clicking on the spotlight icon in
the top right hand corner of the screen.
Or optionally you can hit command and
then space and
that'll bring up the same spotlight
search and then type, xcode.
This will bring up
the Xcode launch screen.
>From the launch screen you can
create new Xcode projects,
open existing projects or
create a playground.
We won't quite be using playgrounds yet.
But they're a great tool for
experimenting and writing swift code.
For now you'll want to open
an existing Xcode project,
the Maze project to be precise.
We've created the Maze project
ahead of time for you, so
if you haven't downloaded
it already go ahead and
download it first before
continuing ahead.
Once you've downloaded the project and
saved it somewhere on your computer,
select Open another project and then
you want to navigate to the project.
So I've saved it on my desktop and you
want to open up the xcode project file.
And we'll give it a second to load,
and here we go.
This is Xcode.
It's a huge application, so we'll
start taking it one piece at a time.
To run the Maze application,
click on the play button in the upper
left hand corner of the Xcode interface.
You may also hear this button
referred to as the Run button.
This will launch the iOS
simulator with the Maze app.
And there we go.
Congratulations!
You've launched your first app.